[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
Press preview a first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive and it's
time to see what's making the headlines
with the political journalist at the
financial times Jasmine Cameron chileshi
and the political editor with the son
Harry Cole they'll be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's see
what's on some of those front pages for
you and the front of the eye looks at
pressures on the chancellor Jeremy Hunt
to boost defense spending or risk
failing to deter Putin
The Daily Mail also addresses defense
questions with its headline Rishi RAF
are ready to shoot down spy balloons
as Sarah everard's killer pleads guilty
to charges of indecent exposure the
front of the Guardian says that police
missed chances to arrest cousins our sex
offender suspect
in the financial times oversees bets on
Vodafone mounters Liberty Global takes
1.2 billion pounds stake that's their
headline the Metro leads on family
tributes to 16 year old Brianna Joy who
was stabbed to death in a park in
Cheshire on Saturday the headline strong
Fearless One of a Kind
and the front of the sun looks at the
Energy company utility Warehouse which
has reportedly sent a hundred of its
reps on an all expenses paid trip to the
Maldives of course during the cost of
living crisis
and the headline on the front of the
Daily Mirror quotes are recently
released convicted murderer I'm not a
threat to victim's lover it says
as you know we're joined tonight by
Jasmine Cameron chileshi and Harry Cole
and uh let's uh very good evening to you
of course and let's uh dive straight in
quite a mixed bag isn't it this evening
but um this story that's got everyone
mystified well the British Dimension now
the balloons and objects including small
cars apparently um floating over North
America
um this on the front of the Daily Mail
Jasmine uh Reese's sonak the Prime
Minister saying the RAF are ready to
shoot down spy balloons well you kind of
would have expected them to be anyway
wouldn't you
yeah so it's quite bold language from
Rishi sunak so he was asked about
um the escalating tensions between the
U.S and China we know over the past few
days the U.S military have shot down
several objects that have been flying
over North American airspace that they
claim have been Chinese by balloons and
so this is Rishi sunak attempting to to
weigh in and also reiterate the fact
that
um the UK obviously is is willing to do
whatever it takes in order to protect
its airspace as well but I also think it
comes at a time where CNAC is under a
lot of pressure from his own MPS to take
a toughen stance against China and we
know that we are waiting on the
government's integrated review looking
into the direction of the UK security
strategy and so it was a message not
only to to China and to other Western
allies but it was also a message to his
own back benches but he's very
um comfortable and very willing to talk
tough on China and to also signal that
the UK isn't going to back down when it
comes to International threats it's
interesting though the length of time
it's all been going on this also in the
article and in other papers as well
Harry the White House confirmed that
China is running a high altitude balloon
program to collect intelligence and a
quote from John Kirby of the U.S
National Security Council these
surveillance balloons have crossed over
dozens of countries on multiple constant
continents including some of our closest
allies including presumably the the
United Kingdom and people will be asking
well why have we been letting it go on
well yeah it's interesting that um the
Prime Minister today when he was asked
he sort of LED very heavily on the
tradition that he wouldn't comment on
the actual specifics he he ducked behind
National Security to say behind his
tough rhetoric whether we had actually
been targeted
um I think the Spy balloon is an
interesting one that was the size of
three double decker buses the four um
objects that have been shot down in more
recent days have actually been some
smaller than a car it's not necessarily
clear they even are spy satellites and
they've been taken out as a sort of
abundance of caution as one of the U.S
generals said
um the United States I was reading today
at 45
000 different planes flying in and out
of the United States airspace every day
that's just commercial then you've got
thousands of military flights then
you've got classified flights that don't
even show up on radar these things are
quite small it's a very very busy
airspace and I think they're only really
seeing them now because they're really
looking for them there's no doubt though
that they've clearly been caught off
guard if it is true that this new front
and the sort of um there's a battle
against China and and hostile states
such as Russia and Iran has taken on a
Bazaar and it's a slightly dated term we
haven't really been talking about hot
air balloons and uh and and some
airships for for for for many decades
now so perhaps I think while we the
world was focused in the in the
cyberspace space sphere and then in the
sort of hypersonic sphere sphere
actually perhaps we've taken a our sort
of foot off the um the accelerator in
studying some more traditional ways of
spying on it each other which is putting
up a balloon now uh as Jasmine said
sunax is an interesting position here
because he has got this defense review
coming up in which he has been resisting
privately
um a further classifying China as a
threat to Britain at the moment it's
considered a systematic competitor now a
creature of the treasury such as Richard
sunac wants to keep as much trade open
with China as possible but this is gonna
make it really really hard for him to to
justify that and it couldn't have come a
sort of worst time for the British
government as they're just about to have
a big fight with as Jasmine said with
their back benches about why they're not
going to be even tougher than they
already are in China okay let's have a
look at the front of the Guardian uh
plenty of different stories on that but
we want to concentrate on of course the
terrible earthquake or earthquakes I
should say as the UN says today that um
at this phase a week on after the
earthquake it's now perhaps a little bit
more about dealing with those who
survived helping those who survived
rather than looking uh for those who may
be still trapped under the the rubble
and uh their headline desperation in
idlib as earthquake compounds Syria's
crises and of course that being plural
Jasmine because we all know what's been
going on for the last 12 years it's very
difficult in those circumstances to to
get Aid to those people
um certainly and you you know you you
feel desperately sorry for for these
individuals who as you allude to you
have been you know there's been lots of
geopolitical
um tensions and upheaval in that region
and then to have a natural disaster on
top of that and a week on from the
actual earthquake we're now getting
these harrowing stories about
um the struggles of survivors trying to
access Aid trying to rebuild their lives
after what has been a terrible tragedy
and I think the questions will be on the
International Community looking at what
can be done tangibly to make sure Aid is
is getting to those people in need to
look at what amounts countries need to
be giving we know that a lot of
countries like the UK for example are
looking at their budgets from the tight
constraints but will also want to make
sure they're they're adhering to their
International obligation and the
humanitarian obligation to help in a
situation like this but you know the
newspapers have been filled with with
some of the images and some of the
stories and it is just heartbreaking and
and know hoping that the International
Community can find a way to make sure
Aid gets to those in need and so people
can start rebuilding their lives
Harry what do you make of it I mean
particularly the the difference between
what we're able to get into turkey and
uh those benighted Syrian people who in
some cases have been just left to deal
with it on their own
yeah no completely look at Turkey it's a
it's touching the source of Europe it's
a NATO country we've had our differences
in the past but obviously we've been
able to get there quickly Visa access
for rescue teams firefighters
um specialist Crews that were that Us
and other countries have donated very
rapidly and then you've got the absolute
Basket Case of geopolitics that is Syria
in the rebel-held areas you've got the
Russian influencer um you've got Russian
Mercers on the ground you've got a a
sort of leper government in Damascus
that you know the International
Community would really does not want to
touch after the horrific Crimes of the
last 10 years and it plays into a wider
you know geopolitical problems you know
relations with Russia
in the Deep Freeze in a way we haven't
seen for for decades since the end of
the Cold War
um how are people going to come together
and work around it and if suddenly
you're talking to the Russians about
what to do in getting Aid into Syria why
not talk to the Russians about other
matters it's going to really play into
lots of other characters around the
world and the clock is ticking the you
know the the death toll alone 33 000 now
Red Cross saying they expect that to
sorry the U.N saying they expect that to
double
um putting making it one of the you know
the worst
um uh earthquakes in recorded history
but then look at the numbers displaced
people not only people already displaced
by the war in Syria pouring into turkey
but millions and millions of people left
homeless uh in in freezing temperatures
and time running out
absolutely Harry that you put that
perfectly I'm going to stay with the
guardian
um top of the Guardian
and I mean Jasmine what do you make of
this I mean it is shocking police missed
chances to arrest cousins as a sex
offender suspect uh we know about uh his
uh murder of Sarah everard but just six
days before he kidnapped her
cousins exposed himself at a fast food
drive-through restaurants on the London
and Kent border and get this this came
up in when he pleaded guilty today staff
reported the incident to the
Metropolitan Police with the full car
registration and details from the credit
card he paid for food with the car was
registered to him
um it's it's jaw-dropic
I mean it is truly shocking and it does
make you wonder what sort of processes
are in place by the Metropolitan Police
to ensure that if there is an incident
where an officer has has been flagged as
perhaps committing a crime or Flags an
instant like this surely there should
have been some sort of practices in
place where he was it was investigated
properly he wasn't still on the streets
and as we know if we look at the
timeline of when he committed these
um offenses it was in February 2021 as
you say just a few days
um before
um he murdered Sarah everard and so it
does really feel like there was a missed
opportunity and I think it comes at a
time when there's a lot of public
questioning over the the Mets obviously
there are a lot of individuals who serve
dutifully it's an incredibly stressful
job but we know there have been a
handful of stories that have touched
upon a culture of misogyny and touched
on issues of race that um have been
identified and so these sorts of stories
it doesn't really instill a lot of
confidence in the force and it does
speech the fact that I think there's a
general feeling among the public monks
some certainly some elements of the
government and home office that there
needs to be a little bit of a shake-up
in terms of how the Metropolitan Police
Works how it trains its officers and how
it picks up when there have been
instances where an officer is engaged in
misconduct and what processes are are
conducted in order to make sure that
they're off the streets and and the case
is handled properly Harry can we have
confidence that the metropolitan police
can can deal with this the I mean the
Christian says what it's something like
a a thousand of his officers that need
to be be looked at re-vetted and dealt
with
yeah I mean not really realistically at
the moment
um it's gonna find Mark rail himself the
commissioner says he understands that
any woman in London now is going to have
extreme skepticism
um of of the met there comes a point
that cleaning out the Stables becomes
um so horrific and uh and and lifting
the lid on things becomes so uh so
traumatic for people that actually the
sheer scale of the number of problems in
the Met perhaps could tip it over into
into into in a place that hasn't been
for a long time there's been discussions
in the in the last few weeks with
ministers MPS uh it's sort of beginning
to realize actually perhaps they're into
a a sort of Tipping Point that's been
reached actually the Met is too big it
has too many responsibilities ranging
from serious fraud to terrorism to
murder in a city that's you know is it
it it could be easily broken up into
smaller police forces that could be more
accountable I think the most chilling
thing in that Guardian piece as well is
the fact that not only did they miss him
say days before but they missed him
before he even joined the met when
cousins was a was a nuclear um nuclear
constabulary officer he had been
reported for an indecent exposure in a
forest in Kent where he was a witness
saw him half naked jumping out of the
bushes they saw his car they reported
his number plate and crucially this was
given to the met the incident was
reported to the met when he appointed
when he tried to switch over from being
the new from the nuclear constabulary to
the Metropolitan Police it was flagged
and the Met decided there wasn't enough
evidence it was an unproven allegation
and allowed him to join the police force
just on the back of that it's
astonishing how LAX it seems that
recruitment for policemen in the
metropolitan police has been and no
wonder that they're in that mess so
there are a thousand cases that need
reviewing if they let anyone in yeah and
Jasmine I mean the chilling thought
about that is that it's not about them
messing it up and being lacks that this
something else in play there
yeah I think so and I think it speaks to
how
um certain crimes are perceived because
say for example um a lot of Charities
and activists have said that something
like indecent exposure for example isn't
really taken seriously by the police or
by forces and authorities more generally
it's it's not seen as one of the one of
the more serious crimes whereas actually
it can it reflects on you know perhaps
the um you know how an individual
conducts themselves how an individual
perceives women and can lead to more to
more violent behavior and so it speaks
to how certain crimes against women are
also seen as well because one report of
indecent exposure should have been
enough to set off red flags but it's
clear that that didn't happen in this
case okay listen we're going to take a
short break now uh Jasmine Harry thank
you very much deed for the time being
coming up we have the cost of living it
upper reports in the sun claiming that
an energy firm flew a hundred of its
reps to the Maldives
on an all-expensive paid
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview uh with me now our Jasmine
Cameron chileshi and Harry Cole
discussing everything that's turning up
in the studio here and uh your paper
Harry front page a bit of a classic
headline cost of living it up has Brit
struggled with bills and energy bosses
sent a hundred reps to the Maldives
complete with a picture of I must say uh
not modestly sized swimming pool there
of some of the the Reps cooling off uh
tell me about the story outrage at the
firm well what is the firm
the firm is a focal utility warehouse
and part of their um incentives for
staff um if they sign up lots of
customers to their tariffs they get
flown out to the mall exhibit scenes I
think um the story has mainly come from
holiday makers who've been pretty
shocked to discover uh on the beach um
all of these reps from from the company
uh one one witness saying they were
handing out business cards and chatting
about how good business was which um at
a time where energy companies ranked
pretty down pretty low down the ranks of
popular
um Industries at a time with Sky High
prices seems remarkably tinnit uh thing
to do and it just kind of shows along
with the
um the sort of sky-high profits of BP
and shell the energy producers
um and the companies that you know have
not really covered themselves in glory
in the last few years being false
Kicking and Screaming into putting you
know the most vulnerable people onto the
lowest tariffs legally
um it's just a real kick in the teeth
for uh for punters of bill pay says at a
time when worry about what to do about
energy devices yes the cost of energy is
coming down but it's still far higher
than anyone's used to and Jeremy Hunt
making lots of noise ahead of the budget
that that the very generous energy
support
um the the customers have had over the
last year is not going to last forever
so bills will be going up this year not
up as much as originally feared but um
when you see pictures like this you can
understand the Public's anger and still
clearly uh judging on that a lot of
money to be made out of it all let's go
to the Daily Telegraph and Jasmine
brexit deal weeks away it reports as
negotiations have solved the protocol
Rao really do you think they have this
is of course the Northern Ireland
protocol it's been a thorn in the side
of relations between the EU and the UK
well ever since brexit
yeah I mean it's quite an optimistic
story in the telegraph although there
have been lots of briefings and and
front page stories about a deal is is on
the table a deal is just days away so
there has been a lot of this in in
recent
um weeks and you know despite that I
think there is a genuine sense within
Brussels that actually the
um seeing that's Administration perhaps
is more open to to compromise there is
an element of the UK left the EU and it
um you know we had the referendum in
2016 this has been dragging out for a
very long time now and there is a sense
of urgency to actually get this over
over the line and there's also pressure
from the Americans and there's a there's
a feeling that this needs to be done
ahead of the Good Friday agreement
anniversary but you know ultimately as I
said these stories have been floating
around for days and weeks and I think
you know we'll have to wait and see if
we have actually reached the final
moment of crunch talk so whether this is
just slightly optimistic well let's take
it at Facebook value that we have and
then Harry perhaps the biggest hurdle
then is getting it past the ERG within
the conservative party and of course the
Democratic unions party in Northern
Ireland uh we're already hearing aren't
we the words sell out
well something as Jasmine will know and
you will know that you know having
covered brexit for six years the just
because you've got a deal in your hand
uh as Theresa May found out with the
European Union and something you could
bring back home and put to MPS means
actually you've now you know that's when
the politics of this really begins this
is almost the easy bit is getting the
deal with the EU it's getting it through
Parliament that is the problem now I
think the ERG are less of a threat
actually than the dup if the if the dup
give this the nod which I'd be surprised
if they did um I can't see the ERG
holding out the Tories holding out if
the actual ulsterman who uh whose
livelihoods are suspected on a
day-to-day basis say it's okay now this
is all going to come down to the
oversight of European judges now the EU
will say actually though The ecj Remains
the ultimate Arbiter of disputes within
Northern Ireland and the Brits will be
able to say well actually no local
judges in Northern Ireland will be able
to do the vast vast majority of dispute
disputes about trade rules or or any
fallouts but ultimately the ecj will
still have some input now the telegraph
article says that this is something that
Boris Johnson resisted and Liz trust
resisted Boris Johnson certainly yes but
I think even in those 49 days of Liz
truss negotiating with the EU and her
role as foreign secretary uh before that
I think that role for the ecj was always
going to be on the table now that is a
red line for the dup however they did
accept in the original terms of Boris
Johnson's divorce agreement some input
from the ecj so I wonder whether
there'll be a landing Zone there if it
looks a lot like the other withdrawal
agreement